there is renewed optimism this morning
about yet another coronavirus stimulus
package to help the millions of
struggling americans
after months of back and forth house
speaker nancy pelosi and senate majority
leader mitch mcconnell are closing in on
the framework for a deal
one that could be passed before
christmas nancy cordes has the latest
from capitol hill
this is normally peak shopping season
but the new numbers
tell a grim story the retail industry
shed another 35
thousand jobs last month 550 000
since the pandemic began families are
falling into poverty
as a result of our inaction congress has
been gridlocked over more relief
since may but suddenly leaders are
talking
and expressing new optimism that they
can cut a deal
fast there is momentum compromise is
within reach their talks come as a 908
billion dollar bipartisan framework
gains traction from both sides the plan
would provide an additional 300 dollars
a week for the unemployed
and it would help small businesses and
state governments
bridge the gap until the economy
improves how
soon do you and leader mcconnell need to
cut a deal
in order to have a package to vote on
before the holidays
we have the time to do it the proposal
does not include another round of twelve
hundred dollar stimulus checks
for americans whose income has taken a
hit it's 30 000 less than what i was
making
carrie mansfield of irving texas lost
her auto repair job in may
and only found a new one after sending
out 150
applications we need that stimulus money
to boost
us consumers to get out there and start
buying
right now my christmas we're not buying
anything this year
congressional leaders are hoping to
attach whatever deal they come up with
to a government spending bill that is
supposed to pass next week
and i'm told that aides on both sides
will be working through the weekend
trading proposals as they try to meet
that very ambitious
deadline for cbs this morning saturday
i'm nancy cordes
on capitol hill